das ist wirklich ein kurioses schauspiel
in doppelsternsystem 40 40
in einer entfernung von 7800 lichtjahren
scheint hier ein schwarzes loch völlig
außer kontrolle geraten sein denn anders
als es schwarze löcher normalerweise tun
feiert dieses ungewöhnliche exemplar
seine materien strahlen nicht in
dieselbe richtung stattdessen eiern die
jets laufend hin und her und ändern ihre
richtung klicks um science-fiction hier
gibt's täglich faszinierendes seines
videos abonniert den kanal nur dann
verpasst ihr nichts herzlich willkommen
[Musik]
bei den sogenannten jets handelt es sich
um gigantische materie strahlen die bei
den meisten uns bekannten schwarzen
löchern die fontänen aus der sogenannten
akkretionsscheibe herausschießen
dabei handelt es sich um eine scheibe
aus gas und staub die fast mit
lichtgeschwindigkeit um das loch in der
raumzeit rotiert so werden heiße plasma
fetzen ins all katapultiert
höchstwahrscheinlich bestehen diese jets
aus nickel und eisen und bewegen sich
mit unglaublichen 200.000 kilometern pro
sekunde ins all
das entspricht zwei dritteln der
lichtgeschwindigkeit forschungsteams
wissen immer noch nicht ganz genau wie
diese sogenannten jets entstehen doch
höchstwahrscheinlich sorgen magnetfelder
dafür dass das material falschen ähnlich
weggeschleudert wird nach auswertung der
chandra daten ist die energie solcher
jets wohl zum einen von der masse und
zum anderen eben vom drehmoment des
schwarzen lochs abhängig auch diese
materie jets des schwarzen lochs im
sternsystem 40 40
verhalten sich ganz anders als in
vergleichbaren system das hat jetzt ein
australisches forschungsteam durch die
analyse in verschiedenen
wellenlängenbereichen mit einem verbund
aus zehn us amerikanischen teleskopen
gezeigt auch der röntgen satellit
integral der europäischen
raumfahrtagentur esa trug einen teil
dazu bei
denn so konnten die experten und
expertinnen bis zum inneren rand der
akkretionsscheibe vordringen fest steht
das schwarze loch in diesem
doppelsternsystem saugt materie von
einem begleitstern ab diese materie
sammelt sich dann auf der etwa zehn
millionen kilometer breiten
akkretionsscheibe und sprudelt dann in
die schwerkraft falle doch anders als
sonst bei schwarzen löchern üblich ist
schlingern die materialien
hin und her das ganze erinnert ein wenig
an eine wildgewordene schlange oder aber
an ein gartenschlauch der außer
kontrolle geraten ist laut der fachleute
ändert der jet seine richtung in weniger
als einer stunde zur dynamik des
schwarzen lochs und der rotierenden
scheibe sagt james will jones von der
esa wir glauben dass die materie scheibe
und das schwarze loch unterschiedlich
ausgerichtet sind das scheint den
inneren bereich der scheibe baumeln zu
lassen wie einen langsamer werdenden
kreisel eine wirklich außergewöhnliche
entdeckungen in 7800 lichtjahren
entfernung
bekannt ist dieses schwarze loch das die
materie seines nachbarn sterns
verschlingt bereits seit 1989 ist ein
stellares schwarzes loch also nicht ein
so riesiges und hat etwa die neunfache
masse unserer sonne also viel kleiner
als das supermassereiche schwarze loch
sagt darius stern im zentrum unserer
milchstraße
das schätzung zufolge 4,3 millionen mal
so schwer ist wie unsere sonne solche
stellaren schwarzen löcher wie das jetzt
beobachtete im sternsystem 404 zu
knicken millionenfach in unserer
milchstraße unserer galaxie vor doch
warum verhalten sich diese jet so anders
und entweichen eben nicht wie gewöhnlich
senkrecht zur scheibe ursache für all
das ist laut ansicht der experten und
expertinnen wohl die supernova aus der
das schwarze noch hervorgegangen war
diese könnte dem schwarzen noch einen
stoß versetzt haben und es so zum
taumeln gebracht haben seine achse
schwankt durch den raum vergleichbar mit
einem kreise
das führt dazu dass auch der jet seine
richtung verändert dem astronomie team
zufolge könnte dies auch bei anderen
schwarzen löchern der fall seien bereits
bekannt ist ein weiteres schwarzes loch
mit einem rotierenden jet der allerdings
sechs monate für einen umlauf braucht
und nicht in weniger als einer stunde
verrückt was wäre wenn ein massives
schwarzes loch neben der erde auftauchen
würde
panik oder was astor comics tv klärt es
hier draufklicken anschauen und
natürlich astro comics tv abonnieren bis
dann bleibt dran